well we're still we're just starting to
get a sense now of
the impact of what we're going through
economically but it's
it's yet to really fully be told on the
official numbers so official
unemployment rates still
uh down at literally a very incredibly
low rate kind of 3.9
but when you scratch beneath the surface
we're now starting to see some of the
evidence
of what's going on and obviously the
furlough scheme is the big
economic story in this country still at
the moment but that's starting
to come to an end at the moment and
we're now starting to get a sense of
what that might actually mean for the uk
economy and let me just show you
a few charts that illustrate that first
of all when we look at the total number
of people
who are in paid employment so paid
employees in the uk we now see that that
is falling
uh very sharply indeed so down just
another leg
uh in the last month down by 730 000
over uh the last few months so a very
big fall
three quarters of a million people out
of paid employment
and when we look at other measures of
what's going on in the labor market you
get a pretty striking vision
that things are not normal right now so
as i say official unemployment numbers
uh are starting to come down but they're
not really showing the full reality the
full reality
is really kind of shown by this chart
now these lines show you the number of
people
who have been temporarily away from paid
work in previous years so relatively
flat there
in the first uh 26 weeks of the year
let's let's bring on this year
and you get this incredibly striking
picture that's about seven and a half
million people
temporarily away from paid work now that
is basically the furlough scheme
and the big question about the economy
right now
is how many of those people come back to
work
after the follow scheme comes to an end
it is ratcheting uh to an end at the
moment so
the prices are going up the cost is
going up for employers
uh the question is how many of those
people come back to work and
what that means for the unemployment
rate and to be honest with you
no one really knows the answer and
that's one of the scariest things
in the uk economy at the moment but we
do know unfortunately
the news is going to get worse